we're good cool so at Netflix right I
don't have any free shows today but I
swear if you come to this intuitive
reason scription it's called a free
trial go sign up it's good anyway a
hundred and thirty million subscribers
just a little bit of us we're wearing
190 countries something crazy 140
million hours of streaming content every
day most of it is from the snail
household apparently so it's good anyway
our biggest thing is you can watch
netflix on basically any device with the
screen and internet connection and
that's largely kind of more promise you
know we have some over the years we've
developed some really nice responsive
user interfaces so this is kind of the
latest iteration where everything is
responsive videos playing real time this
is probably what you guys are familiar
with if you are a subscriber anyone
remember with this one this is 2009 this
is what the site looked like so it's a
little bit different and kind of look
the the thing that's kind of got us to
go from 2009 in this view to this is the
how do we make that change but how do we
go from that really sort of integrated
view of the site to this we do a lot of
a be testing to get there so we don't
just make changes of the site randomly
we actually a be test everything so
every little change that you make on the
site every little product design
improvement anything that happens to the
algorithms they're already tested in
fact we do a lot of a/b testing at
Netflix when I say a lot I mean really a
lot like a thousand thousands of a/b
tests a year each of them has tens or
twenty variations so it's a lot of
changes happening to the service at one
time and as most of you know actually
the service is made up of a bunch of
micro services on the backend so here's
a live view of Netflix traffic one of
our data centers and literally there's a
lot of 200 services that make up the
Netflix data graph so quite a lot of
services each of them is responsible for
a small part of Netflix and not all of
it and so the question I want to post
the audience is how
do the clients of what you have you know
quite a few out in front talk to all the
back-end services right today I'll talk
to each other at once 200 services lots
of devices probably not the best idea
and we thought we thought so too and so
instead we have something called the
Netflix API that both the back-end
services and the front-end devices talk
to and this gives us that flexibility to
be able to integrate both the front and
the back end without having to make
changes having each each of them make
changes to each other and you see what I
mean in a second so the API decouples
clients from the back-end services and
it provides an integration point for
both services and clients and what's
really important actually is that we use
something called the BFF pattern so the
backend for phone and pattern who's
heard of that quite a few folks great so
the big premise of this is that you have
a client and you have a service the
front stuck that serves that client and
these are very tightly coupled and if
you imagine the Netflix app or the
experience your iOS app looks very
different than what you see on your TV
but it looks very different than what
you see in your browser right and so you
want these things to be tightly coupled
together so that when client engineers
are pushing code to the to the devices
they're also pushing their services in
lockstep and using using the Netflix API
we can look and we can also abstract
away kind of the rest of the Netflix API
and so you can make individual changes
to your client and your service without
having to affect the rest of the Netflix
stack and move at a higher velocity and
these buckets like we said before these
BFFs are maintained by UI teams since
it's tightly coupled to their UI and
what this means is you know they don't
fly engineers they don't necessarily
have the expertise to run services at
scale in fact we hire them to not do
that we hire them to write responsive
user interfaces you know and it's really
hard to maintain and write services that
skill generally even if your back-end
engineer and so I want to talk a little
bit about the API requirements and how
that fits in with function as a service
in JavaScript right so we weren't really
high velocity for these BFFs since we're
making you know two or three changes a
week to each and every single client
they need to be really reliable
if one of these things is downed and the
entire client is unavailable and that's
that's not good for our customers it
needs to be really easy to use and we
want to abstract away the operations
because again a target audiences for
like client engineers who have no
experience writing services and so I
think this is kind of where function as
a service JavaScript and node really
come in handy and we'll talk today about
how we're building a function as a
service platform in Netflix and how we
use that to unlock the ability for
client engineers to be able to run their
own services that's highly available low
latency and super performant and so
before we can talk about function as a
service I want to talk a little bit
about the evolution of function as a
service and kind of cloud computing
general in the industry so in the very
beginning you had everyone who owned
their own data centers right before the
cloud before you see to you you own like
the literal data center itself and the
walls and the machines you also own the
services platform you don't the
application and you also own the
business logic somewhat somewhere you
know in the 2000s 80s came along and now
they were able to abstract away using
infrastructures of service the data
center itself and so now instead of
having to build your own do the center
and get your own get your infrastructure
you could just provision that using ec2
but you were still responsible for the
services platform the application as
well as your business logic then we'll
do the industry move to platform as a
service so now we abstract away the
services platform as well but again you
still own the application and the
infrastructure sorry the application and
your business logic and you still have
to own the the operation set of it and
then finally today I think this new
paradigm is emerging with function as a
service where you know we abstract away
everything right everything's managed
for you except for the business logic
that you want to write and I think this
is helpful to think about because for
our client engineers this is really
important too because they don't really
care about any of the infrastructure or
the operations or the platform they just
care about the business logic that's
specific to their app and I think this
probably finds a lot of common ground
some of you here as well who do that
kind of stuff and so when we're thinking
about building or bought versus buying
our own function as a service platform
this was a few years ago
lot of questions came
because one of the biggest questions is
you know how come you guys aren't using
insert some third-party service function
as a service solution at the time there
wasn't really anything in the market
that could support our scale or
integrate with our ecosystem or that was
built for request responses services
most of the offerings out there were
really for event-driven workloads and so
we decided to build our own and so we'll
cover kind of the platform today in
three steps three sections the runtime
platform architecture the developer
experience as well as management
operations of the function platform so
let's talk about the runtime platform
architecture and before we can talk
about the function as a service platform
and want to go back to this diagram
because I think we need to talk about
how we're building infrastructure and
platform in general Netflix so talk
about infrastructure as a service most
of you probably know were completely
hosted on the cloud using AWS and kind
of ec2 is that common base level of
infrastructure that we use to run every
single service though with that exists
right however as we were building the
function of the service platform we
decided actually instead of just using
VMs we decided use two containers as the
foundation and the reason that was just
how to do that was that it gave us a
bunch of these advantages which make
sure there are platforms that art was
ergonomic it was efficient and was and
we had a really great develop malossi so
are some examples containers are much
much much more quickly than your closet
VM would so we can get deployments and
startup times on the order of seconds
instead of minutes and they're really
portable across multiple environments so
you can take a docker image and run that
locally or you can take your image and
run it remotely or in a cloud or vice
versa
and that's really helpful for debugging
as an example and for our cloud
infrastructure costs we were able to
more efficiently PIM pack using
containers because we were able to do
scheduling ourselves on top of the ec2
instances already owned and so as a
result of our decision to use containers
we built a technology called Titus which
is our own container management platform
it's it's really high scale open-source
platform that allows us to schedule and
launch millions of containers per day
I encourage you guys to check it out
it's it's really its own talk so we're
not gonna get into the details of this
here but it is like the substrate that
allows us to run containers at scale and
Netflix and so let's talk about the
platform right and what does it take to
actually run an application at Netflix
so we've created our own reliable and
open source services platform some of
you probably have already seen it or
heard of it but it's again it's open
source online but it provides us with
its really a set of components that you
need to be able to run a reliable
service things like service discovery or
RPC or configuration metrics etc there's
a whole bunch of stuff that's built in
really too many to list all of them are
open source and you can check them out
and so sometimes I get asked the
question why are you guys to building
function as a service if you already
have this really robust platform I can't
teams just assemble all this stuff on it
on their own and just use it well it's
kind of like going to Ikea and you want
to buy a chair right um you see the
chair at the at the story like this is a
great chair I'm gonna take it home and
it comes home in this pallet of parts
and you have to go assemble these parts
yourself it's kind of like that with
services right we have this great store
of really robust platform pieces but you
have to assemble them as a team yourself
and so often you do it wrong right and
this is kind of what we're trying to
avoid you know and then we have two or
three hundred engineers so we're gonna
be building these services we want to
avoid them to have to experience that
pain right wait so some of the
disadvantages where you have the key
always keep the components updated to
the latest versions yourself and so we
know for example that update time you
update your application change one of
the modules or the dependencies one it's
painful one - it's not something that
you really want to be doing and three it
could you know yeah there's always the
likelihood that you could introduce bugs
you also have being sure that the
metrics and dashboards are creative for
your service and none of these things
are automatically generated so again
getting visibility and ultimately
because you own the infrastructure and
the platform so you're on the hook for
managing and operating the
infrastructure so none of these things
are ideal for that use case we're
looking for which is we have client
engineers they need services they don't
want to have to operate them right and
so you shouldn't have to set
from scratch every time when literally
all you want to change is the business
logic and so let's look at the function
as a service platform right and the one
of the thing that we've built and here
are some of these requirements that we
have there's no assembly that should be
required all the parts automatically
update themselves reliably you get
observable metrics and visibility into
the into the service and the operations
are managed for you and so ultimately
the overview of the platform is it's a
services container that we've
preassembled with all those components
that we just talked about that's ready
for a production service we start with a
docker container and inside I wish to
drop a whole bunch of daemon so we need
to be able to run a service reliably so
things like discovery and metrics and
log rotation we also bring a node
because the function is a service
platform run JavaScript and instead of
our node process we have a bunch of
libraries that we load for you as that
as the application developer so
everything that you need to write to run
a service reliably and then we have an
HTTP server and really only instead of
they're the things that are highlighted
in red which are your route handlers
those are the only things that you have
to worry about and right so this
everything else outside of those little
red boxes is already pre-assembled for
you and this is I think a really
powerful idea of function as a service
and server list in general which is
you're kind of abstracting away all the
common pieces so that all that's left is
just a differentiation part which is
just your business logic we also
packaged in version the platform as a
single entity so instead of in those 15
different components you have to keep up
to date yourselves we do it for you and
release those as a single version of our
function as a service platform and so
what that means is we can update upgrade
the fleet uniformly we can make sure
that everything is well tested that
every time we do a platform upgrade that
our customers aren't being affected and
because we control the runtime right we
can make sure that the platform emits a
consistent set of metrics for every
function that's installed in the
platform so again when you go and
operate the system all the functions all
the metrics then alerts already set up
for you and so we did set up we sound a
bit of about fastball form to try to
solve these issues and I think we did in
terms of not having this demo
pre-assemble anything
getting automatic updates and having
observable metrics and we'll talk about
the manage operations aspects of it in
the third section we're talking about
operations so let's talk about the
developer experience right this is also
really important how do you actually
develop on this platform in the new kind
of server this function as a service
paradigm so we can talk a little bit of
the about the development API functions
are managed by our configuration API so
most of these fields are optional but
they give you a way to declaratively
state and declare what your API looks
like right so yes some things like this
name of your service and the platform
version and what's really important I
think is the ability for you to declare
your own functions so you can declare
the verbs their HTTP verbs as well as
their sources we give you the ability to
add additional source code that you
might want to bring in as a part of
those functions and then there's stuff
like configuration and lifecycle
management which are really important so
that gives you a way to one configure
your app but also introduce additional
things into your functions at the
beginning of process start which we'll
get into in a little bit and then the
business logic themselves the functions
are literally just your connect cell
middleware which everyone here should be
super familiar with otherwise you're at
the wrong conference but basically you
know they're literally your your
standard we uh you know expressed
specify whatever middleware not everyone
is super familiar with and you just have
to export one of these out of your
JavaScript files that we import and so
this is like a vanilla example of it but
you know it can get pretty complicated
if you want to add additional business
logic but one of the nice things about
our platform is you know by default all
of the platform components such as your
metrics and agents and your loggers your
RPC clients are all initialized and
ready to go for you when your function
is loaded so you don't have to
initialize those and so by the time your
function executes everything is there
and ready to go and again this is really
important because you're no longer
having to do the set up and back to the
analogy of the chair you could assemble
it wrong and here everything's just set
up for you ready to go and this also
improves kind of the velocity the
developer velocity that we're looking
for for our developers and you know
here's another example
where
we you may want to bring the additional
components to your functions and
traditionally you would do that in your
regular lab because you've access to
like index jets or whatever your main
function is and you can start stuff
because you can't in this environment we
give you the ability to do that by a
start up and shut down hooks where you
get access to kind of the function
environment you can start any set of
additional components that you want and
those are live for the rest of the
lifetime of the process so these are
good ways for you to add additional
things like database drivers or
additional logging loggers or whatever
it is you need like the cou same the
hooks are initially before the platform
starts and they have access to all the
platform components and so it makes it
really easy for you to integrate any
additional libraries that you need
additionally any external dependencies
can be imported from NPM which is really
nice it's real you know as a developer
you usually use a lot of other code so
all that stuff can be imported into your
functions and so our goal here was to
also create a local function development
experience that improves the software
development lifecycle for developers as
well so we have this great runtime API
for you to write code how do you
actually develop on your local desktop
right and so what we've done is created
a work full toolkit called mute and this
simplifies and facilitates like common
developer tasks right and like typically
the example I would give is you started
a new company what's the first thing
that you have to do before you start
coding you have to install all of the
ear in your entire environment on all
the dependencies right so this tool has
looked with one-click setup and then get
your developer desktop to be consistent
with everyone else's and installs all of
the dependencies that you might need to
start developing and so we've also
created a development function as a
service platform for local development
and so now you can interact to test your
functions in seconds right reducing
friction and increasing velocity and the
way that works is you have local
functions that you you start developing
and you instead of a git repo somewhere
and what we do with docker is we drop a
local container on your desktop with the
entire fast platform that's loaded and
instead of having to rebuild the docker
image every time which takes forever
you actually do a live reload across
your your host and the guest docker
container and that way when you make
changes to your code that gets file
synced into the local container that
restarts and then you have access
basically to the service as it's running
locally and this is really nice because
you can now look at logs you can attach
the buggers you can hit the endpoints
everything's there locally and you get
this truly native experience and it's so
in this in addition to being with work
on stuff locally you can also integrate
your local container right in with the
Netflix cloud because a lot of our
devices for example they need they need
there sits all terminated or they need
authentication or they need DRM
decryption and we have services in the
cloud that does that and so we can route
device traffic into the club back help
to your local container for you to do
testing on and that routes back into the
rest of those back-end services for you
to integrate against but sometimes you
also want to be able to test functions
in isolation without having to connect
to or depend on upstream or downstream
services right and so how do we enable
that use case well we let you test your
isolated local functions like providing
mocks and unitized API right and the
hard thing about providing unit tests is
that a lot of these components that
you'll need generally require you to
talk to a downstream service and so
we've provided mocks for these services
so that you can easily mock them out and
then run these testing isolations so
here's an example where we've got a
whole bunch of mocks coming in and now
you can test your functions of isolation
without having to make network
connections and so this developer forum
can also be easily deployed to Jenkins
and this allows us to unlock like the
CIC deep aspects of it of for teams so
they can have nice CIA pipelines set up
to make sure that we're improving you
know quality and reducing bugs and so
lastly we'll talk about the management
operations aspects of the platform and
this is kind of where we really want to
make the platform truly service and I'm
gonna abstract away the infrastructure
for a member wyne right so generally
speaking
getting your code to production involves
these steps right you need to publish
your code deploy to production and then
operate on it and so the way that
publishers
work with the platform is you literally
just publish your functions and we
create an image of your function and we
version that in a centralized religious
tree so there's no you know there's no
there's a command let you publish and
then that's read that's what what's
happening underneath the hood is that we
combined a docker image of our base
platform with your functions and create
a new docker image and then that's added
to our centralized function registry for
all the teams so every team kind of has
a bunch of apps function of fast apps
and each of them will have different
versions
every time you publish these versions
are unique and you immediately save to
the registry and now we can publish
these functions to the cloud by our new
the new commands that we talked about
earlier but this is kind of our suite
the developer tooling and so here you
can see you know a one-liner which
that's just to play a set of functions
to the cloud really quickly right in a
span of a few minutes we're now live and
these functions are deployed using titus
which is that function orchestration
system I talked about earlier what
happens is they did we take the function
from the registry and then the titus
container scheduler that goes that goes
ahead and schedules them into the cloud
for us we use things like Canaries and
canary deployments of analysis as part
of the deployment which helps us
minimize outages and increase
availability and these are all
automatically added to your function
deployment process so whatever you
deploy you can choose to have Canaries
and these are a good indicator for you
to figure out if a new new build is is a
good candidate or not and we do an
automated analysis where we look at
specific metrics to make sure that hey
you know your new functions look just as
good or it's not better than the old
ones and then every single deploy
function version can be managed by our
control plane so I blanked out kind of
some of the RPS numbers but here for a
specific team you can see the various
versions of their functions that's
running you can see how many instances
of each one you have time stamps you
have links back to the git repository
and all the detailed historical
information and deployment and
management activity is available to
eight debugging as well so you know next
time something happens you'll see like
oh I did an appointment and that's
what's causing failures for you
we also use auto-scaling to
automatically scale the infrastructure
for each function and this saves costs
and increases availability and all you
have to do is you require an initial
configuration for each function that
you're deploying and like I said earlier
metrics and dashboards are automatically
generated for each function so that you
know you have full visibility into into
your service
a lower so generator and they're tied
into page of duty for each of the teams
so the goal here is really to automate
and sort of provide a lot of value out
of the box
and we have things like we're making
real-time and historical observing that
you deploy profiling and post-mortem
tools a lot of the work that we've been
doing with kind of the diagnostic
working group we make all of that
available for these services as well and
so the ones the other thing I would add
is of being for structure in the
operations of this platform and the
application is actually handled by the
centralized platform team and so the UI
teams are only responsible for manage of
their own individual functions and
they're only on-call if there's problems
with that business logic but if there's
problems with infrastructure or the
platform itself that's handled by a
centralized team and this kind of gives
you that server list operations
environment so today we talked about our
fast platform we talked about the
runtime platform architecture and how we
use node docker and the Netflix platform
to be able to enable it people to write
functions as a service we talked about
the developer experience a way to give
you native to bump a native development
experience locally and our develop a PS
and we talked about management
operations right and how we provide
tools and I'll whole suite of tools and
metrics for us to easily manage your
functions and so I want to take up to
sort of leave you with a bit of some of
the lessons that we've learned along the
way one of them is that you need really
solid foundations and so before we could
build function as a service we needed a
really robust infrastructure service and
platform of service platforms and if we
didn't have those we wouldn't be able to
build function as a service so if you
think you've going down this route it's
really important for you to first invest
in your infrastructure in your platform
the developer tools are also really
really important in order for you to
unlock
Devon malossi that you're looking for it
to get with fast you want to make sure
that you invest in the development
experience right so how do you make the
development phase as native as possible
and then lastly investing the operations
tooling as you go up stack and abstract
away a lot of the infrastructure and
platform away from your developers they
now no longer get access to like the
actual instances or they lose ability to
see some of the tooling so how do you
think about how how do we provide
tooling up stack like the like the way
that we can automate it automatically
generate flame graphs or give them
access to metrics or logs by a web UI to
make it easier for them to offer their
service so I talk to you today about our
fast platform I think the thing that I
will leave you with is that you know
JavaScript a node and function as a
service I think is like this natural
evolution of where the web is going it's
really worked great for our developers
is allow us to get really great velocity
and improve the operational and
availability for service and I really do
think that like there's there's
something to be able to run JavaScript
on the client my JavaScript on the
service and really unlock the potential
for you developers and thank you very
much
[Applause]